the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video in this video
i will show you what happened shortly
after the red wedding if you haven't
read a song of ice and fire you might
not know this happened because it was
never shown in any of the seasons of
game of thrones now i am sure most of
you have heard of lady stoneheart i'm
assuming that most game of thrones fans
have heard of her over the years however
you might not know exactly how she was
found believe it or not it was actually
arya stark who found her mother's body
only three days after the red wedding
massacre what makes this scene even more
interesting is the fact that arya was
actually inside the mind of her direwolf
nymeria as she finds her mother's
lifeless body floating down the river
this is another thing you wouldn't have
seen in game of thrones the show would
have us believe that bran is the only
stark who can go inside of his direwolf
but if you read a song of ice and fire
you will see that all of the star kids
are capable of this in this chapter you
will see that arya actually thinks she
is dreaming when this happens and at
first glance you might not notice it
either unless you're familiar with how
this works now if you remember from the
show arya stark and the hound were right
outside of the phrase hall during the
red wedding as her mother lady catelyn
and her brother rob are dying inside the
hound hits arya on the back of her head
with his axe before she can go inside
and get herself killed as well only a
short amount of days after this is when
arya while inside of her direwolf
nymeria sees her mother floating down
the river now i will read exactly what
it says in arya's chapter in a storm of
swords
[Music]
the king in the north arises
[Music]
the lannisters and there are guards
[Music]
where are you going arya asked again the
hound finally answered her you have an
aunt in eerie might be she'll want to
ransom your scrawny arse though the gods
know why once we find the high road we
can follow it all the way to the bloody
gate on liza the thought left arya
feeling empty it was her mother she
wanted not her mother's sister she
didn't know her mother's sister any more
than she knew her uncle blackfish we
should have gone into the castle thought
arya they didn't really know that her
mother was dead or robbed either it
wasn't like they'd seen them die or
anything maybe lord frey had just taken
them captive maybe they were chained up
in his dungeon or maybe the freys were
taking them to king's landing so joffrey
could chop their heads off they didn't
know we should go back she suddenly
decided we should go back and get my
mother she can't be dead we have to help
her i thought your sister was the only
one with a head full of songs the hound
growled frey might have kept your mother
alive to ransom but there's no way in
seven hells i'm gonna get her out of his
castle all by my bloody self not by
yourself i'd come too said arya he made
a sound that was almost a laugh you're
just afraid to die she said scornfully
now clegane did laugh
death don't scare me only fire
now be quiet or i'll cut your tongue out
myself and save the silent sisters the
bother it's the veil for us arya didn't
think he'd really cut her tongue out he
was only saying that the same way pink
eye would always say he'd beat her
bloody all the same she wasn't going to
try him sandor clegane was no pink eye
that night she went to sleep thinking of
her mother and wondering if she should
kill the hound in his sleep and rescue
lady catelyn herself when she shut her
eyes she saw her mother's face against
the back of her eyelids she's so close i
could almost smell her and then she
could smell her the scent was faint
beneath the other smells beneath moss
and mud and water and the stench of
rotting reeds and rotting men she patted
slowly through the soft ground to the
river's edge lapped up a drink then
lifted her head to sniff the sky was
gray and thick with cloud the river
green and full of floating things dead
men in the shallows some still moving as
the water pushed them others washed up
on the banks her brothers and sisters
swarmed around them ripping at the rich
ripe flesh now just in case any of you
haven't noticed already arya is now
inside of nymeria and nymeria's friends
are now starting to eat some of the dead
bodies the crows were there too
screaming at the wolves and filling the
air with feathers their blood was hotter
and one of her sisters had snapped at
one as it took flight and grabbed it by
the wing it made her want to crow
herself she wanted to taste the blood to
hear the bones crunch beneath her teeth
to fill her belly with warm flesh
instead of cold
she was hungry and the meat was all
around but she knew she could not eat
the scent was stronger now she lifted
her ears up and listened to the grumbles
of her pack the shriek of angry crows
the whir of wings and the sound of
running water somewhere far off she
could hear horses and the calls of
living men but they were not what
mattered only the scent mattered she
sniffed at the air again there it was
and now she saw it too something white
drifting down the river spinning where
it brushed against a snag the reeds
bowed down before it she splashed
noisily through the shallows and threw
herself into the deeper water her legs
churning the current was strong but she
was stronger she swam following her nose
the river smells were rich and wet but
those were not the smells that moved her
she swam after the sharp red whisper of
cold blood the sweet stench of death she
chased them as she had often chased a
red deer through the trees and in the
end she ran them down and her jaw closed
around a soft white arm she shook it to
make it move but there was only death
and blood in her mouth by now she was
getting tired and it was all she could
do to pull the body back to the shore as
she dragged the body up the muddy bank
one of her little brothers came with his
tongue hanging out of his mouth she had
to snarl to drive him off or else he
would have fed
only then did she stop to shake the
water from her fur the white thing lay
face down in the mud rise she thought
rise and eat and run with us the sound
of horses turned her head men she
thought they were coming from downwind
so she had not smelled them but now they
were almost here they were men on horses
with flapping black and yellow and pink
wings and long shiny claws in hand some
of her younger brothers bared their
teeth to defend the food they'd found
but she snapped at them until they
scattered that was the way of the wild
deers and hares and crows fled before
wolves and wolves fled from men
she abandoned the cold white prize in
the mud where she had dragged it and ran
and felt no shame
when morning came the hound did not need
to shout at arya or shake her awake she
had woken before him and even watered
the horses they broke their fast in
silence until sandor said this thing
about your mother it doesn't matter arya
said in a dull voice i know she's dead i
saw her in a dream the hound looked at
her for a while then nodded no more was
said of it
we don't find out until the next book
why nymeria left her body there when she
ran off
those men arya heard while she was
inside of nymeria were the brotherhood
without banners after nymeria fled the
scene thorus of mir and beric dondarrion
found lady catelyn's body lying in the
mud we find out exactly what happened
next when thorus of mir is having a
conversation with lady brienne he said
the frey slashed her throat from ear to
ear when we found her by the river she
was three days dead harwin begged me to
give her the kiss of life but it had
been too long
i would not do it so lord barrack put
his lips to hers instead and the flame
of life went from him to her and she
rose may the lord of light protect us
she rose
now what i would have given for all of
us to have been able to see this on the
show now imagine what this must have
felt like ferrari she hadn't seen her
mother in years and right when they were
about to reunite she basically hears her
mother and brother getting butchered
inside the castle then although she
thought she was dreaming she found her
mother's lifeless body floating face
down in the river as if witnessing her
father's execution wasn't enough
it's no wonder she slowly becomes a
vengeful murderous assassin who only
wants to see her enemies dead i would
have been right there with her now if
you actually think about it lady catelyn
would have never been resurrected as
lady stoneheart if it wasn't for arya or
i should say nymeria grabbing her body
from the river thorus of mir and beric
dondarrion only found her because arya
brought her onto the shore if she
wouldn't have done that i don't think
they would have found her on their own
now lady stoneheart has a list of names
of her own just like her daughter it
would actually be insane if arya and her
mother find each other somewhere down
the road as they go and massacre members
of house frey and lannisters together
let me know what you think about this
scene especially if you haven't read a
song of ice and fire did you even know
this happened and or let me know what
you think will happen with arya and lady
stoneheart and the winds of winter
assuming we will ever see it as always i
want to thank each and every one of you
for watching the video i hope all of you
have a great day bye
[Music]
[Music]
you